we begin with multiplication of a vector
by a scalar when you multiply a vector a
by a scalar this multiplicative factor
just three scales the magnitude or the
length of the vector let us look at the
vector two times a this is in the same
direction as the vector a but is twice
as long this is vector B a vector is
defined by its magnitude a direction so
this vector B is the same anywhere in
space including if the origin if I want
minus 0.5 times B this vector is in the
opposite direction of B and is half the
length now let's look at vector addition
here's a vector a here's B how do we add
them graphically we slide the tail of B
to the head of a and their sum is a
vector drawn from the tail of a to the
head of B I could have also added a to B
by sliding the tail of a to the head of
B you can see that this makes a
parallelogram and the sum vector C is
just the diagonal of this parallelogram
subtraction can be thought of as just
multiplication and addition if I have C
is equal to a minus B I just need to add
a to the vector minus B minus B is
negative 1 times B which is this vector
here now I only have to add a 2 minus B
let's do another example here are my
vectors a and B do not start at the
origin but since vectors are the same
anywhere in space I can go through the
process here I want a minus B so I first
multiply B my minus 1 to find minus B
and then I move the tail of minus B to
the head of a and add the two like this